[Music]
my name is Howard I'm from the
Philippines my company is called matcha
bit and our game is called balanced IO
after the bootcamp we realize a lot of
things that we thought were in the game
didn't the program boosted our skills as
a developer by helping us see things
from the user side better we got
feedback from mentors on how to think
like a user and how to observe users
better one of our games that was having
trouble getting good reviews and
downloads basically jumped up to a 4.7
star rating after getting some feedback
of what to do with the game and another
game got featured and it was able to get
a good number of downloads and reviews I
would recommend this program to other
indie developers because any indie
developer no matter how good they are at
their craft can still get better
it's basically training that you never
thought you needed nothing could be
better than that for people who want to
get better
you